they are dispiriting scenes for
ukrainians russian soldiers posing
showing off after taking lissy chansk
russia has performed better in recent
combat in eastern ukraine
the russian armed forces continue to
strike military facilities in ukraine
says the military official including
airstrikes on u.s made missile launchers
in donetsk
but the ukrainians remain defiant
we will return said president vladimir
zelinsky ukraine he says does not give
anything up
while the russians appear willing to
wage a long war of attrition against a
smaller ukrainian military the
ukrainians are motivated to fight for
their homeland and are being resupplied
with more long-range military hardware
from nato there's going to be more
equipment flowing into ukraine from the
west
the russians are exhausting their
supplies to a certain degree this can be
very difficult for both sides
but i think it's going to be
particularly hard for russians the war
has become a grinding battle for land in
eastern ukraine from crimea to the
donbass russian forces have slowly
seized control of almost all of the
luhansk region and uk defense
intelligence now expects russia's focus
to switch to capturing donetsk to
achieve moscow's stated goal of
liberating the donbass this may be
russian president vladimir putin's end
game to secure control of the donbass
and forced ukraine to accept the
ceasefire on those terms then he can say
that he liberated these territories and
now it's on on to ukraine to accept that
reality so i think that's what his
objective is right now but whatever
gains russia is making on the ground it
is losing on other fronts the loss of
the european marketplace for russian
energy will have long-term consequences
germany has depended on russian energy
for too long chancellor olaf schultz
saying the country must get off russian
energy as quickly as possible and then
there is the expansion of nato this
isn't a historic day for sweden and
finland the two nordic countries moving
a step closer to joining the alliance is
a disastrous outcome for moscow which
had aimed to divide and weaken the west
two well-developed countries that have
modern militaries and can
add much to the alliance
so
this is an absolute failure
for putin
the sad reality for civilians in ukraine
is that the war shows no signs of
winding down soon it is one more way in
which russian success on the battlefield
may yield few benefits having destroyed
much of what they have taken over and
rousing anger and destroying relations
with a next-door neighbor that could
last generations
eric sorensen global news toronto